I wish we would sometimes go to state
governments do you think we would that
we could end up like that over here get
go more individual State statewise like
you know the original sort of conception
where everybody has their own little
their own little Vibe yeah I think it
would just be I mean it would make
Sports would be so much more exciting
because you would be like if yeah if
Georgia is playing California they are
playing California yeah yeah well that
that is what's cool about like I love
soccer obviously and that's the one
thing American Sports misses is that
like these are countries that literally
fought each other like when you have
[__] Algeria playing France those
[__] colonized Algeria like
Algeria wants to [__] them up so it is
cool but yes I think you're right it
would be a real there'd be a real melee
situation I think about that sometimes
where it's like yeah what does happen if
we just you know everyone everyone calls
each other's Bluff and we're just like
[__] you [__] you we're separate
countries and then we see what happens
yeah I think it would be really exciting
and I think well it would definitely be
more exciting and also the states are
getting really different you're having
states that are like going bankrupt
you're having states that are keeping it
together you're having states that are
like um you know that can't take care of
their people you have in states that
that can take care of their people you
know um you have states that have like
legal gun carry and states that you know
it's like I think you're getting they
seem to be getting more separate than
together and I think we as a country
seem to be getting like that at times
yeah I mean it's also [__] huge you
do think about it you're like this
really shouldn't be one country we
really should break it up you know I
would love to have a couple countries
yeah give a couple countries you know
still no pass still like like the EU I
can go vacation there yeah you know what
I mean I don't want to have to do a
bunch more paperwork to get in right but
you know that's the other thing you know
the culture War [__] would get so
annoying where it would be like if
you're from New York and you just want
to come hang out in the South you know
they would [__] they would [__] with
you a little more and vice versa you
know what I mean they would be like
Yankees yeah yeah yeah absolutely You'
have you'd have to wear like a gay patch
yeah you know if you went to if you were
gay you mean oh to let like a star David
thing or whatever there' be certain
place where it's like if you're trans we
want to know yeah put a patch on we're
put the trans patch on we just want to
know what we're dealing with coming to
Florida yeah look it's it's hunting
season just started and some of these
guys can't see well so we
want his patch on look if you have uh if
you're sexually uncertain we need you to
put this orange vest on yeah exactly
yeah cuz we want to know if we [__] you
if it's gay or not that's it nothing to
do with you it's all about our
accounting we keep track of our own
you're on vacation we're not going to
[__] with you but if you get sucked off
by our pal he gets one gay strike and
then he can't yeah three strikes and
you're
out three strikes they take a little bit
of your penis away unless you get
elected to be a senator you get two more
strikes yeah that would
yeah that would be yeah that's
interesting it would make yeah making uh
state government even gayer which is
hard to do dude I just put I I think I
would it would be neat there would be
more like excitement about your state I
think or you would have to take more
State responsibility yeah I think um
what would some be some of the the good
points of that I wonder well I think a
lot of it would be you would get to
decide how to spend the money I worry
that I think it's a good idea in theory
and again I don't [__] know cuz it's
been so long since I've actually known
[__] like this but I think a lot of
states depend on federal funding way
more than we realize yeah just say
Mississippi if you want to right right
right right right I think what would
happen is like uh um and and also it's
like once you stop being different once
you stop being like you could in theory
be like well we're not going to spend
money on the military like there could
be like you know liberal states are like
we're putting our money into whatever
the [__] and then it's like first of all
who gets all the who gets all the B all
the [__] planes that's would we play
like rock paper scissors for that [__]
well the military would still have to be
a general consensus unless you'd have
state military as well right but you
would you what you're talking about
essentially is becoming independent
countries basically or coalitions you
know what I mean like if you broke it up
into four states maybe divide it up by
population yeah maybe it would be yeah
it would definitely be exciting bro to
have that go on In Our Lifetime like who
we started out a country we couldn't do
it couldn't do it and so we started to
separate why wouldn't you [__] up the
like the liberal C the liberal country
though like it just feels like it would
be a quick like all the place with guns
if I were a gun guy yeah and we and you
gave if you took you know New York and
La these huge economies it's like why
don't we just go [__] kill those guys
like it would be why would you just
declare war and be like dibs on you know
this [__] yeah oh I think definitely at
New Year's
when it was like the time where you
shoot guns in the a I have a feeling
everybody would just turn their guns
right over to the state they don't love
yeah yeah absolutely so the bullets all
flew over there like d we got well who
knows who knows where it comes down not
not my problem I'm
celebrating you're just unloading the
clip or an Albanian wedding maybe let
the [__] clip let the clip sing Let
The Chopper sing for an Albanian
wedding
oh dude that's fun man I would live
where would you I would have to stay I
would have to stay in the whatever
Northeast uh country would be I would be
a New York guy I think so you would yeah
I think you would be a BAL as long as
BAL of Baltimore yeah yeah yeah I would
hope Baltimore New York would be in one
kind of
midatlantic I think that's what would
happen you'd have kind of like a you
know what I mean you'd have clumps it
wouldn't be just 50 it wouldn't be 50
countries what we're talking about here
oh you say we probably get down to about
maybe 20 States or something 20 maybe 10
you know what I'm saying maybe [__]
five who [__] knows what if it was
some weird state that formed all across
them like Georgia
fornia and it was like this they just
took or just yeah took all the coastline
they're like we're the Beach State suck
my dick you want to come to a beach you
got to [__] you got to go through me
that would be [__] [__] dude if
San Francisco like commandeered like all
like certain like like all the they
owned like certain rest areas along the
way yeah well that's what you do with
the homeless put them to work give them
a couple guns give them you know what I
mean like you would have you would have
the you you could have the homeless
Marine Corps you know what I mean where
it's like they just got needles you know
they got little Wolverine hand needles
coming at you you know what I mean
that's oh or they're all they have like
a big needle yeah yeah one giant needle
and they just load it up and just yeah
and then they just run and inject it
into somebody
yeah yeah yeah is it Fenty is it
hormones who knows yeah dude I got Nan
you're hitting each other with different
needles yeah yeah that is interesting
because my my gut reaction would be well
Whoever has guns you know Southern
States whatever would [__] it up but
every every time I feel like you look at
Fox News it's like a different guy
that's so scared to go to New York City
who's like the toughest guy it's like
you have guns and [__] but you're scared
of the homeless so it's kind of a
natural it would it would be a natural
like stalemate where it's like we a wall
of patrolling and then give him houses
give him little sick homeless Huts lean
toos on the outside absolutely get a
shanty town say if they did divide into
States right so Louisiana there was a
time where they were giv Federal funding
and they said we had to change our
drinking law from 18 to 21 can you pull
that up Alex what that's [__] and we
said [__]
you bro we said [__] you not only are we
going to be drunk yeah but we're going
to let our roads deteriorate so we
drive the following year there was like
7,000 drunk driving desk they're like we
[__] try us [__] we don't
care they're like it's babies with fetal
alcohol syndrome
driving yeah it's Albanian babies pull
up an article just if you see something
like that that's [__] awesome dude
yeah I respect that so much but we tried
I remember uh to do that and for a few
years just stood up and everybody's
excited we can drink you know but then
everybody's F kids were dying and
families were dying like a manbe we
shouldn't drink yeah yeah yeah yeah for
three years yeah yeah yeah um it is
funny though if you watch like clips of
when they pass drunk driving laws people
are just like are you [__] kidding me
in my own truck the government is trying
to [__] now they're in my F-150
what's next you know what I mean it's
like people fight good like any
regulation tooth and nail which like
it's like the way a baby's like I'm not
going to bed suck my dick and then they
you know they wake up and this look
let's say this this baby does smoke
cigarettes and has had a history of
gambling online to be able to say that
kind of stuff yeah yeah very he's got a
dirty mouth foul mouth this baby yeah
this baby worked offshore for a couple
years